public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
stéphane le foll candidat au poste de
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
est l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous ce soir ancien ministre de
l'agriculture ancien porte parole du
gouvernement vous êtes candidat pour dit
vous faire exister le ps entre emmanuel
macron et jean luc mélenchon pour vous
interroger ce soir stéphanie le rouge de
la fp et jean francis pécresse le
directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique et éditorialiste aux échos
vous répondrez à trois grandes questions
1 attractivité de la france est ce que
vous dites bravo macron qui attire
aujourd'hui quelques 140 grands patrons
étrangers à versailles de immigration la
politique suivie et elle à vos yeux
équilibré comme le dit le chef de l'état
3 la compétition pour la tête du ps
pourquoi vous trahan commence tout de
suite avec la première de ces trois
questions
[Musique]
et donc 140 président aux directeurs
généraux de grandes sociétés
internationales sont réunis aujourd'hui
ce soir à versailles et ils vont dîner
avec le chef de l'état est ce que vous
dites
pour ce plébiscite en quelque sorte
bravo macron gère d'abord que il ya eu
un déplacement du président de la
république à valenciennes toyota oui
c'est des sans emplois créés
investissement qui a dû être décidée à
mon avis hein
il ya déjà quelques quelques temps et
qui devait prendre en compte une
situation économique qui s'amélioraient
pour que toyota investissent à ce niveau
là donc l'attractivité
c'est un ensemble qui fait que
aujourd'hui il ya des investissements
que la croissance économique est là
alors après versailles pour la france
son image une habitation pdg du monde
entier pour pouvoir investir en france
bon c'est une opération de communication
très bien mais l'attractivité c'est
aussi l'ensemble des décisions qui sont
prises
moi je sais ni bravo ni c'est pas bien
c'est une manière toujours de faire en
sorte que notre pays soit un pays dans
lequel y ait des investissements et donc
de l'emploi et donc de la richesse
enfin ce que vous faites pas un peu la
fine bouche vous dites c'est une
opération de communication il ya aussi
un élément nouveau peut-être c'est à cet
élément nouveau ça s'appelle confiance
et pourquoi est ce que ce qui ce qui
marchait pas ou ce qui marchait mal
avant tout d'un coup semble se débloquer
c'est une investisseuse ans et une
arrivée qui me totalement contestée
c'est que cette question regardez il ya
eu près de 300000 emplois qui ont été
créés et je crois en 2017
des investissements ont repris dès la
fin 2016 bon il ya une continuité et
c'est tant mieux
dans un environnement de travail et
nouveauté la nouvelle république une
personne qui s'appelle emmanuel macron
et mais j'ai bien vu j'ai rencontré chez
politique aussi au fait que ces bilité
du travail oui il ya une politique et de
l'aveu même du président de la
république emmanuel macron elle n'aura
d'effet que dans deux ans voilà donc si
il ya des gens qui viennent aujourd'hui
à ces départs il tire gloire aujourd'hui
de résultats qui nous ont menés sur
loire il fait ce qu'il a à faire pour
appeler à des investissements en france
mais je rappelle que sur la question
d'investissement et les repart
avant et l'année 2007 a été une année
justement qui marque 2010 est une vraie
tendance est oui avec une investissement
extrêmement forts qui avait commencé je
ne m'appelle je les nie à la fin de
l'année 2016
un peu tard par rapport au quinquennat
de françois hollande oui mais cette
reprise elle est là et cette
consolidation économique elle est là en
tous les cas il ya quelqu'un qui était
beaucoup plus optimiste enthousiaste
plutôt que vous ce matin sur radio
classique c'est l'actuel ministre
d'économie à l'ecoute bruno le maire il
il évoque ce prêt davos donc un mis sur
pied aujourd'hui par l'elysée sur radio
classique
j'avais 140 chefs d'entreprises parmi
les plus grandes entreprises la planète
qui viennent à paris qui disent tiens
c'est là que ça se passe
c'est là qu'il faut investir et pour
nous pour le miz de l'économie que je
suis c'est vital parce que derrière ces
désinvestissements c'est la
modernisation d'entreprise ce et des
sites que nous pouvons revitaliser ces
des emplois qui sont créés donc oui
c'est un événement majeur et pour sogeti
pour la france et qui est un signal très
clair que voilà la france elle est de
retour
il ya une chose dont je suis certain
guillaume durand c'est que la france qui
augmente les impôts qui augmente sa
dépense publique qui creuse sa dette qui
creusent sens d'éthique commerciale
comme c'est le cas depuis des décennies
à la tire personnes quel politicien je
rappelle que fin 2015
la france a réuni 195 pays 195 et là
c'est pas 150 chefs d'entreprise ces 195
pays pour une coop 21 qui a débouché sur
un accord avec laurent fabius comme
ordonnateur et grand organisateur de
cette comme 21 tôt que la france était
présente sur la scène internationale
puisque ça veut dire de montrer comme ça
qu'ils auraient une rupture totale et
que d'un seul coup la france serait de
retour
c'est très politicien mais ça m'étonne
pas uno lauber une tendance à faire
beaucoup de plus de communication que
d'objectivité
voilà c'est tout est ce qu'après je ne
suis pas là pour dire que c'est mal où
ces braves aussi enthousiaste non je
suis là pour rappeler des faits mais
j'aimerais bien que de temps en temps
vous de mon sens où viennent on vous
appelle d'autres c'est ce que vous avez
bien sûr qu'il était intervenu en
quelques mots
je vous pouvez peut-être comme une forme
d'hommage est ce que vous ne voyez pas
une fuite une sorte de parallèle entre
la com 21 fin 2015 est l'événement de ce
soir est ce que c'est pas au fond une
copte 21 de l'attractivité de la france
mais a lieu ce soir du tout 150 chefs
d'entreprise par rapport à 195 pays
désolé de vous dire que la comparaison
est vite fait
ça y avait mais ça c'est si c'est pour
la question de la france
ce que j'ai entendu c'est de dire que
cette réunion à versailles
je vous rappelle aussi que laurent
fabius avait organisé sur la question de
la gastronomie à versailles un grand
événement sur l'attractivité sur le fait
que malgré et après des attentats qui
nous ont touché le tourisme dès 2017 est
revenu à un niveau extrêmement élevé ça
faisait partie des stratégies d'ailleurs
qui avaient été fixés et par le
président de la république et par
laurent fabius
franchement soyons objectifs sont
justement je vais vous faire
il ya beaucoup de partis pris à crayons
objectif regardons les choses telles
qu'elles sont alors on va tendre à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on se serait retrouvé
avec une france qui est de retour comme
si elle avait été absente avant et je
vous rappeler si jean yves le drian
corps et jean yves le drian s'il l'a dit
c'est une erreur alors voilà ce que
d'une prise à leur île et églises de la
défense je me souviens que les premiers
rafale pour ne parler que de la question
d'armement on a vendu des rafales camp
quand on était aux affaires
et qu'on diriger la france alors c'est
votre ancien collègue effectivement vous
l'avez côtoyé au gouvernement et lui il
dit effectivement que le regard sur la
france a changé le dit dans une
interview au figaro ce matin en ces
termes la france a aujourd'hui une force
et une capacité d'influencé que nous
n'avons pas connu depuis longtemps
depuis longtemps dit il
c'est pas très sympa de sa part si vous
l'avez dit ressentez vous l'avais dit
c'était moi rien - interrogations les
boss c'est pas très sympa non c'est pas
très sympa mais surtout c'est pas très
objectif
keaven macron avec son élection et
d'ailleurs il en a fait un enjeu
politique
sur cette scène internationale soit
présent c'est pas moi qui vais contester
que cette présence eux à l'échelle
internationale dépendent aussi un
contexte très particulier
angela merkel elle n'était pas du tout
dans la situation de laquelle elle est
aujourd'hui quand nous sommes
et quand françois hollande est arrivé à
la présidence de la république le vrai
qu site affaibli la grande bretagne a
qu'à voir les débats d'aujourd'hui et
puis quand à de vale trump il isole
politiquement et diplomatiquement les
états unis donc il ya un contexte
international qui donne une visibilité
emmanuel macron et à la france un leader
chez montpellier rêveur je fais pas mon
plein mais de dire à partir de là que l
aurait été absente avant je fais
simplement le constat je voulais dit
qu'elle a été plus que présente
puisqu'elle a été capable de faire en
sorte que les pays du monde viennent en
france
et si un accord exceptionnel sur la
question de lance des fans et des gens
qui vous parlez de l'allemagne ce que
vous approuvez le choix du spd de
continuer les négociations pour la
grande coalition côté l'allemagne a une
tradition de grande coalition
ça a existé avant le choix du spdc choix
du spd il ya eu un débat au spd il ya eu
un vote
j'ai bien compris dans l'instance de
représentation des qu'après il y aura me
semble-t-il si j'ai bien compris
martin schulz y est engagée à nouveau un
vote avec les adhérents du spvm en tant
que c'est un choix qui relève du spd
avec 2 vous auriez préféré que le spd
disent stop
non mais moi je me prépare une opinion
sur éventuellement la grande coalition
de nora je n'ai pas jeudi la france vous
êtes engagés notamment avec emmanuel
macron oui est ce qu'il a fait la
démarche qu'il fallait auprès de la
vienne des manuels macron aprilia c'est
un choix oui je vole un mois l'a prouvé
hier que dans ce débat et le spd est en
situation où c'est à lui de décider et
je ne vais surtout pas venir interférer
dans un débat d'ailleurs qui a l'air
d'être assez serré quand c'est vrai on
peut donc une nouvelle génération qui
pose plus à gauche
il faut rester extrêmement là dessus
respectueux des règles et des choix qui
ça ne fait pas dans le sens d'une
affirmation de la gauche en europe
mais la coalition et la négociation sur
le contrat de gouvernement parce qu'en
allemagne c'est comme ça que ça se passe
il faudra regarder exactement ce qui
dans ce contrat va porter sur des
avancées et des choix politiques qui
sont mortes et par la gauche allemande
et donc par la gauche européenne
j'ai enfin fait je crois que martine
choses sur ce sujet d'ailleurs sur la
question européenne
les engagés question parce qu'elle est
liée aussi à l'attractivité de la france
sur l'exe position universel de 2025 le
gouvernement a pris la décision de ne
pas faire cette exposition universelle à
paris est ce que vous le regrettez au
titre précisément de là le rayonnement
présentation une certaine vitrine du
savoir faire français
la technologie alors non seulement je
regrette je crois que c'est une erreur
moi quand je suis arrivé mise de
l'agriculture il n'y avait rien de
préparé pour l'exposition universelle de
milan sur la gastronomie la
l'agriculture durable
rien j'ai donc repris ce dossier du
début et j'ai construit un projet qui a
conduit à une impasse villon de la
france qui a été reconnu comme le
premier en terme d'architecturé en bois
une halle dans un domaine de
l'agroalimentaire et la gastronomie qui
était essentiel pour la france je suis
arrivé c'était il n'y avait pas de
projet donc j'ai repris ce projet je les
portais alors là sur l'exposition
l'avait pour un de 25
qu'est-ce que c'était des expositions
universelles que j'ai constaté à milan
ça vient de 20 millions de personnes
la france a été dans cette exposition
justement à l'avant aux gardes a été
reconnue a été commandée reste
plébiscité en tout cas dans ce cas était
le pavillon et lorsque j'attendais
d'avoir aujourd'hui à saclay avec un
cercle et à la recherche en vain le
enjeux de la recherche les grands enjeux
liés à l'attractivité de la france je
pense que c'est une erreur alors après
qu'ils aient des choses à caler pour que
ce projet soit financièrement tôt nabeul
les tenues qui est encore des choses à
corriger peut-être mais d'envoyer une
lettre jour lendemain en dix ans la
france se retire
je trouve que pour l'attractivité de la
france pour l'engagement de la france et
là je le signale d'ailleurs au passage
le président de la république
emmanuel macron avait dit qu'il y était
favorable je ne sais pas ce qu'il s'est
passé entre ce qu'a dit le président de
la république
emmanuel macron favorable à cette
exposition universelle
et puis alors quelques semaines puisque
c'est un deux trois mois après un après
midi comment un courrier en dix ans on a
bien une analyse
du dossier sur le plan économique
manifestement il faut imaginer rails est
ce qu'il ya eu discussion
est ce qu'on a essayé de corriger des
choses parce que j'ai l'impression que
ça a été très vite et de considérer que
l'exposition universelle de 2025
c'est ça serait la cause du nombre
d'anneaux d'équilibré budgétaire
alors je rappellerai d'ailleurs à
monsieur le maire que si j'ai bien vu la
loi de finances pour 2018
le déficit budgétaire qui est de moins
de 60 qu'il ya autour de 67 milliards
qui est donc moins important que celui
qui avait été voté par là votre finances
sous le gouvernement précédent on était
à 69 ont fait 67 milliards est bien
celui qui est prévue pour 2018 crois
qu'il est à 80 87 milliards qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire alors
matière expliquer aux français que la
bonne gestion ça consiste à augmenter le
niveau du déficit budgétaire au sein de
paris alors j'ai d'abord l'attractivité
face aux déficits emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui même a promis devant la cour
des comptes de réformer les retraites
1 et l'action de l'état mais la cour des
comptes pointe une situation dégradée
même si la france va repasser sous la
barre des 3%
est-ce que selon vous la hausse des
rentrées fiscales doit profiter
entièrement à la réduction du déficit
puisqu'on il ya aujourd'hui une hausse
des rentrées fiscales avec la croissance
mais c'est la rentrée fiscale doit
profiter à la france de manière globale
à la loi sur les investissements qui
sont nécessaires à faire sur un certain
nombre de dépenses publiques et en même
temps sur la réduction du déficit en
même temps si si nous avons été capables
comme tout sommes arrivés avec un
déficit qui devait être autour de 95 97
milliards de le ramener à 69 milliards
aujourd'hui si nous avons été capables
en même temps que nous faisions ça de
ramener le déficit de la sécurité
sociale de 20 milliards à 400 millions
tout en ayant de l'esj des choix
d'investissements dans l'éducation
nationale ce sont des choix que nous
avons assumé parfaitement et avec les
deux objectifs sauf que là qu'est ce qui
s'est passé est bien c'est qu'on a
comment dirais-je dépensé près de 25
milliards sur les cinq ans sur l' isf et
le prélèvement obligatoire une fois le
prélèvement forfaitaire unique plutôt
vers la fin de sa classe la callas
craque c'est brutal 25 milliards sur
cinq ans à mai mais maintenant on va se
retrouver avec quelques difficultés
ça c'est une erreur pour vous vous ne
dites que c'est le président des riches
même si la wii
ah oui regardez regardez ce que vient de
sortir oxfam à la veille de davos sur la
concentration de la richesse
patrimoniale dans le monde dans le monde
dans galement dans le monde dans
l'oreillette et la france il ya échappé
d'ailleurs sous le quinquennat de
françois hollande les inégalités se sont
légèrement votre conclusion sur le
président macron oui c'est quoi ça te
dire que c'est un choix fiscal qui est
celui de données avec cette idée qu'on
connaît bien
des facilités au capital en pensant que
ces facilités fiscales vont faire que
les gens qui ont de l'argent vont
investir je dis simplement une chose et
moi je le devais faire non pas avec la
question sociale derrière des inégalités
qui est déjà un point majeur mais sur le
fait que quand vous avez de l'argent
vous cherchez à avoir des placements qui
sont sécurisées et avec les rendements
les plus sécurisés penser que en donnant
et en dépensant 5 milliards tous les ans
25 milliards sur cinq ans ceux qui ont
de l'argent vont investir dans des start
up
je dis que c'est une erreur a les deux
ne se fera pas deuxième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité stéphane le foll
nous allons maintenir l'épreuve
d'ailleurs d'autres sujets c'est une
époque on l'espère pour vous d'autres
sujets d'actualité vous attendent et il
sera notamment question de l'autorité du
chef de l'état
[Musique]
avec une première question sur
l'immigration est ce que selon vous la
politique suivie par le chef de l'état
comme il le dit est équilibré elle s'est
trouvée déséquilibré depuis octobre
novembre circulaire de gérard collomb
alors qu'il y avait eu un équilibre qui
avait été trouvé je rappelle la
politique qui a suivi bernard cazeneuve
qui a été d'une politique qui a cherché
cet équilibre entre une maîtrise
absolument nécessaire des flux
migratoires parce qu'on pourra pas
raconter des histoires aux français et
en même temps la nécessité d'avoir une
politique qui tienne compte de la
dignité et d'humanité nécessaire à des
vis des hommes des femmes qui sont et
qui fuient leur pays
ça a été la ligne il était suivi il ya
eu une inflexion
on a voulu faire de ce débat avec la
circulaire que l'on un débat politique
et là il ya un déséquilibre est en train
de se créer voilà c'est très clair pour
moi est ce que vous parleriez d'une
forme de d'une oppression politique à
l'égard des populations qu'on veut
concerné de calais 2 alors j'ai pas de
l'information qui irait jusqu'à affirmer
une force extrêmement violente vous
savez dit yann moix garage et vous ça
alors j'ai vu son texte ce matin dans
libération
il a juste carrément le chef de l'état
d'avoir instauré un protocole de la
bavure de la violence et de la barbarie
à calais je commence je vais réaliser en
lisant ça je reste je réagis comme je lé
fais oui je considère qu' il ya eu un
changement de ligne politique par
rapport à ce que nous avons fait et je
rappelle comment bernard cazeneuve a
conduit la fin de la jungle à l'époque
d'une manière extrêmement comment
dirais-je efficace puisque le résultat
était là et humaines puisqu'on a réussi
à héberger tout ce qui le met dehors
est-ce qu'on en serait là stéphane le
foll si les délais d'étude de l'asile
avaient été réduits sous le quinquennat
précédent a fait défaut des legs gira
que l'on veut réduit
dd que gérard que l'on peut réduire et
on avait mis ça en place et d'ailleurs
on a augmenté le nombre d'emplois à
l'oph royal ofii à l'époque on l'a fait
qu'il faut qu'on a accru jura mais l on
est passé de 20 mille cada un de
demandeurs d'asile à des centres
d'accueil à 49 on a doublé le nom pour
justement pouvoir à la fois hébergés et
traiter les dossiers et accélérer les
durées ça a été fait mais il faut alors
mois en moyenne pour que oui c'est trop
long mais il faut continuer mais ça va
le faire le gouvernement
mais ce que je vous dis sexualité
commencer d'accord mais on est loin des
droits qui sont l'objectif aujourd'hui
mais on avait observé
si c'était si simple bien sûr je saurai
quand même un décor cosy sur des sujets
extrêmement complexe et on doit avoir
des objectifs mais cet objectif de la
réduction du traitement des dossiers du
droit d'asile a été engagée alors vous
parliez de l'ofii le patron de l'office
et insurgés la semaine dernière contre
voilà ce qui aujourd'hui protestent
contre la politique du gouvernement en
disant qu'il y avait déjà des
recensements qui était fait sous le
précédent quinquennat dans les centres
d'hébergement d'urgence
est-ce qu'il ya pas une forme
d'hypocrisie de votre parc et oculi
presse assure j'ai aujourd'hui quand
vous ne vous dénoncez le fait qu'ils
aient une circuit est ce qu'il y avait
nommé un effet qu'il existe déjà il y
avait une circulaire qui existaient pas
puisque elle a été signé par gérard
collomb moi je veux bien qu'on me dise
qu'aujourd'hui on s'insurge sur soi
disant des choses qui aurait été fait
avant moi je sais une chose c'est que ni
bernard cazeneuve
ni manuel valls ni brune rooney matthias
fekl non signé deux circulaires qui
consistait à dire elle ce qui soutient
entièrement la brume et manuel valls
il est maintenant à la république en
marche donc ce sujet là il peut
s'exprimer mais à l'époque ça n'a pas
été fait c'est pas vrai
l'intermédiaire voit là aussi il faut
pas simplement faire de la politique en
faisant des commentaires ou en disant
des choses alors que les faits sont là
sur ces recensements dans les centres
d'hébergement
encore une fois c'est un recensement
votre concurrent dans la course à la
tête du ps
julien dray par le de rafles est ce que
il fait une faute de carre quand il
parle de rama jeudi des combats sous le
terme mais je suis les tv ici notamment
su mais très clair ce qui est en train
de se passer avec ces recensements c'est
pire à la fois en termes humains etc en
termes d'efficacité parce que si vous
laissez environ ya pire que quoi pire on
en parle de gens démographe le la wii
j'ai mes skis et moi je ne parle pas du
mot raf je vais pas faire de commentaire
sur ce que d'autres disent vous dis
simplement et j'en ai discuté avec des
associations que lorsque vous mettez
l'idée et vous instiller l'idée que dans
les centres d'hébergement qui sont
simplement fait pour héberger des gens
qui sont dehors
qu'est ce qui va se passer mais les gens
resteront dehors voilà c'est tout et en
plus de dire qu'on va faire des
recensements le pensez bien qu'à ce
moment là il va y avoir un réflexe qui
va consister à dire je n'y vais pas non
entre recensement que vous assumez
comment et puis rachat il ya un gouffre
alors le mot courage doit vous choquer a
voulu marquer avec ce mot des raves sign
c'est parfaitement identifiés dans
l'histoire ça une logique je n'ai pas
utilisé ce mot je veux pas passer mon
temps à mentir alors que disent les
autres sujets de la politique migratoire
notamment avec la grande bretagne
je vous propose de découvrir les
résultats de la première question de
notre sondage exclusif
opinionway pour l'épreuve de vérité
faut-il dans le contexte du bric site
que la france continue à coopérer avec
le royaume uni 68 % de oui 29% de noms
que dit à un moment le ministre de
l'économie manuel macron au moment du
bric cite d'ailleurs il alexis avec
brick site
il faudrait renégocier les accords de
touquet qui sont ceux qui régissent
aujourd'hui les règles je le dis
simplement par rapport à ce qui est
souvent rappelée par tout le monde
jeudi j'ai dit j'ai dit des choses et je
les mets en oeuvre où je fais ce que
j'ai dit et ça change de l'habitude sur
ce sujet en tout cas ça a changé
moi je me souviens de ça et là
aujourd'hui
bien sûr qu'il faut continuer de
coopérer bon mais c'est parce que disait
emmanuel macron quand il avait été je
crois que même en grande bretagne en dix
ans il ya le bric site il faudra
renégocier l'accord du touquet deuxième
question de notre sondage opinionway
diriez-vous qu emmanuel macron fait
suffisamment respecté l'autorité de
l'état
oui à 63% non à 35% vous vous répondez
oui
non il ya tout à fait et oui plutôt oui
alors aux français oui plutôt oui plutôt
et donc là nous allons aborder un titre
à base de disneyland ainsi oui plutôt
d'accord on a bien compris
justement on va maintenant aborder
ensemble de sujets stéphanie et jean
francis sur lesquels l'autorité de
l'état est en jeu qui commence surtout
les nationalistes corses parle par
exemple sur la question des prisonniers
politiques corses le gouvernement ouvre
la porte à une relocalisation vous savez
d'un certain nombre de prisonniers
corses qui sont aujourd'hui sur la sur
le continent est ce que vous êtes
favorable est ce que ces prisonniers
soient rapatriés soit rapprocher de leur
famille en corse
moi j'ai pas favorable et dans quelles
limites enfin largement c'est la limite
je ne suis pas fort à val d'oise un
choix qui serait global on rapatrie tout
le monde au cap liés de manière comment
dirais-je négocier discuter des
rapatriements parce que il ya eu du
temps qui s'est passé que aujourd'hui on
doit trouver les voies d'un apaisement
et d'un retour possible dans les prisons
corses d'un certain nombre de détenus
moi je pense que ça doit faire partie
d'une négociation ce qui est engagée
c'est de dire est ce que verse à
l'humeur globale du ray par exemple à ce
moment là l'assassin du préfet erignac
lé dakor annoncé la question je vais
vous poser
non pas tant lui ont donc justement mois
par rapport à ce que je vais vous dire
je ne suis pas pour une politique
globale donc ça ne peut pas concerner
tout le monde d'accord qui est des
négociations des discussions qui sont
engagés oui sur la langue corse sur la
reconnaissance de la langue corse est ce
que vous êtes ouvert à une
reconnaissance de la langue corse
moi je suis d'origine bretonne et je
parle un peu breton donc je sais ce que
c'est que les langues régionales que je
suis pour la promotion des langues
régionales la question qui est posée
c'est d'avoir la langue corse à
l'équivalent en langue française dans
les 1
là c'est un sujet là où on va au delà de
ce qui est la promotion le développement
d'une langue et des landes d'ailleurs de
clarence barrières sont
qui sont des langues qu'il faut
continuer à développer et j'étais
partisan comme d'autres d'ailleurs que
la france signe cette charte européenne
des langues qu'on n'a jamais pu signer
parce qu'il ya toujours une opposition
ici en particulier au sénat contre cette
reconnaissance et ce besoin absolument
nécessaire culturellement de donner
beaucoup d'espacé plus d'espacé aux
langues aux langues régionales
alors après là c'est la question c'est
une langue officielle aux fichiers à
l'équivalent du français là il ya une
question constitutionnelle mais pas
forcément mais là euros contre moi je
suis pas favorable mais paf avant très
défavorable à aller jusque
reconnaissance mais voilà à des
promotions reconnaissance aussi on met
pas deux langues officielles mais une
langue officielle
d'autres sujets sur lesquels on
également notre dame des landes donc le
gouvernement à annoncer sa décision la
semaine dernière est ce que c'est un
affaiblissement de l'autorité de l'état
dans la mesure où on pourrait considérer
que l'état a plié devant les analystes
est ce que je sais c'est que les indices
ont été extrêmement violents
j'étais au gouvernement lorsque on a
essayé de faire évacuer la zad je m'en
souviens parfaitement l'alliance elle
était là et elle était extrêmement forte
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que on n'a
pas été jusqu'au bout parce qu'il y
avait une résistance violente
extrêmement extrêmement forte qui aurait
nécessité la mobilisation de normes
aimant de moyens avec des risques je
vais pas revenir sur des sujets que vous
connaissez à partir de là le choix a été
fait je constate simplement que sur la
voie départementale aujourd'hui ce sont
les artistes eux mêmes qui vont l'ouvrir
c'est une voie départementale donc elle
est donc
donc là je pense qu'un affaiblissement
faire très attention à ce sujet parce
que demandé à beaucoup de jaude français
de respecter toutes les règles en termes
d'urbanisme jeu
10 c'est quand même des sujets qui sont
extrêmement encadrées en termes
d'installations en terme de deux
d'utilisation du domaine public est
considéré qu ici il y aurait ça serait
des choix qui serait fait d'abord parce
qu'ils l'ont occupé et ils verront
comment ils vont le libérer bon je sais
qu'à préfète de région doit aller là
aujourd'hui mêmes stats et ou pas il ya
quand même à à la fois prendre du temps
la peine d'aller se précipiter et moi je
ne suis pas pour des confrontations mais
il ya quand même à rappeler des règles
républicaines tout simplement mode
public c'est un espace public et tout le
monde doit pouvoir y accéder
pas été rappelé et mise en oeuvre sur le
quinquennat précédent puisque c'est si
facile et je vous expliquais que quand
on a voulu y aller je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez je crois pas vous pouvez
aussi de la question de sivas ça a donné
un ton qu'on est dans un esprit en
épandant un espèce dont on était dans un
dans un choix extrêmement difficile et
plus ça allait plus que ça devait
mobiliser alors qu'ils avaient le
terrorisme qui étaient là nous a
conduits à être dans la retenue
je deviens contre les choses pas tout le
pas tout le monde au gouvernement
peut-être monsieur ayrault mais pas
manuel valls qui permet de les mener à
bien cette opération c'est vous souvenez
donc jamais un fil à linge ans de
l'avion il a mené cette opération césar
je me souviens très bien oui et jean
marc ayrault avait dit à un moment parce
que la violence était extrême qu'il
fallait arrêter l'opération
on a renégocié d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de choses je m'en souviens très
bien puisque en tant que miss de
l'agriculture
j'ai été saisi l'histoire d'un parking
de la réduction des surfaces utilisées
je le dis parce que c'était clos de
cheyrou qui avait été chargé d'ailleurs
de faire cette concertation
j'ai participé mais je sais qu'après la
difficulté était toujours la même c'est
elle le fait qu' on avait un risque
majeur de violences extrêmes du
quinquennat manuel valls dit que c'est
bernard cazeneuve qui voulait pas
engager cette évacuation merci manuel
valls se dit c'est qu'il doit le savoir
et je pense que bernard cazeneuve et
souvent des bonnes raisons allez encore
une question soit je saurai ce que la
nuit un jour bernard cazeneuve ses 25 à
26 compagnies de mobiles qu'il fallait
mobiliser non seulement pour l'évacuer
mais après pour la garder
dans un moment où on était en 96 95
plein terrorisme ça c'est un vrai sujet
est ce que vous pensez vous de cette
soirée notamment à l'aéroport de notre
dame des landes ce que vous affirmez
vous voulez faire de l'écologie un des
axes forts de votre je les envoyais je
les dis si on résume une seule question
de l'écologie des changements de modèle
de production d'évolution des modèles de
développement
à la question de notre dame des landes
là c'est sûr que ça va faire un
préalable mais ça ne ne se pose pas
comme ça c'est bien plus large que ça la
question du trafic aérien
vous verrez d'ailleurs que l'idée qui
consiste à dire je ne fais pas notre vin
des andes et je vais faire une extension
de nantes atlantique
d'ailleurs c'est un peu contre si on
parle le même sujet d'hier j'augmente
quand même le trafic aérien
donc c'est pas c'est pas tout à fait
cohérent puis deuxièmement ça ne se fera
pas je ne comprends pas mais alors
qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire en fait le
nom mais qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire
la décision mais vous savez parfaitement
compris non ils vous faites semblant 1
je vous ai dit que face à la violence il
ya là il y avait un sujet de de faire
respecter l'état de droit mais avec
l'engagement qui était nécessaire
d'utiliser le recours à la force à la
force
deuxièmement on a cherché à légitimer ce
projet avec un vote qui s'est exprimé
sur le rhin tandis que leur après des
discussions on va pas y revenir
ce vote a été à 55 % favorables il n'est
pas appliquée à partir de là la décision
le premier ministre l'a prise à pas
faire le commentaire de ce qui s'est
passé avant il ya une décision qui a été
prise que je vous dis tout simplement
c'est par exemple sur nantes atlantique
l'idée qui consiste à compenser le
nouvel aéroport par une extension de
nantes atlantique
je vois pas d'où tu qu'elle est si on
parle de la question écologique quel est
l'intérêt l'admiré et je sais d'ailleurs
que tel que c'est parti ça ne se fera
pas non plus facile mais il ya encore
beaucoup de questions sans réponses pour
la région de l'ouest et fédéraux
dernière que le mouvement des
surveillants de prison là encore on a le
sentiment que cet exécutif hérite d'une
situation laissée par le par le
précédent mais par les effectifs
beaucoup en solo et dans les précédents
exécutif mois voilà je travaillais pas
le dire mais c'est mieux comme ça
mais qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire c'est
ce qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui par
contre qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
si je
les cotisations alors si je prends la
question et continue demain vous avez vu
la situation dans laquelle se trouve
emmanuel macron et le pays aujourd'hui
économiquement donc ce qu'on a laissé
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur
migaud ce n'était pas quelque chose d'à
sincère c'est quelque chose de concret
qui donne des marges au gouvernement
pourrait aussi considérer que faudrait
quand même évité de dire tous les
problèmes on les adc c'est pas vrai donc
séparément déficit budgétaire sérieuse
mais j'aime autant je le rappelle est
sûre on manque de postes
il ya les questions revalorisation qui
sont posées via la question de la
protection des des personnels
pénitentiaires sont ces trois sujets
sont dans une négociation il faut
avancer sur ce sujet voilà des
établissements spécifiques pour les
radicaliser moi je pense que sur la
question des établissements et à la fois
il faut construire des prisons on le
sait on avait jean jacques ne voit ça
avait prévu un plan il faut le faire il
faut le mettre en oeuvre et ça prendra
du temps et en même temps faisons
attention à créer des points et des
pôles de fixation unique sur les en
particulier détenu radicaliser faut
trouver des protections plus fort mais
je pense qu'il ya aussi à réfléchir sur
ce qui peut être fait de manière globale
sur la question de la prison pour faire
en sorte qu'on ait aussi des
surveillants qu'ils puissent travailler
dans de meilleures conditions avec des
précisions plus adaptés en fonction des
peines des uns et des autres allaient
troisième partie d'al épreuve de vérité
nous allons maintenant évoquer votre
candidature à la tête du ps
[Musique]
donc la question qu'on vous a posé tout
à l'heure c'est pourquoi vous stéphane
le foll est simplement parce que vous
seriez le cela a percuté selon votre
mozin percuté mélenchon évoqué peut-être
aussi un peu beaucoup macron moi je
considère qu'aujourd'hui dans le débat
public et politique
après le choc de cette élection de 2010
cette élection de emmanuel macron les
partis traditionnels j'ai pas besoin de
beaucoup mais tendre pour considérer
qu'ils sont dans une grande difficulté
le parti socialiste en particulier bon à
partir de là il ya deux ans je le
premier c'est effectivement d'adapter de
renouveler de changer les parties et le
parti socialiste en particulier ce n'est
pris d'engagement et je pense que c'est
le premier point mais on ne peut le
faire que si on est à nouveau entendu
parce qu'un parti politique n'a de sens
que lorsqu'il présente des candidats et
candidates aux élections et qu'il y ait
des électeurs qui viennent voter
donc si on n'a pas cette double
stratégie et si on n'a qu'une stratégie
on n'arrivera pas au bout à redresser
relevé un parti qui connaît aujourd'hui
des difficultés
c'est pourquoi je pense que ce qui est
souvent critiquée ou qui met souvent
reproché l'expérience que j'ai le fait
que j'ai été porte parole
ça peut au contraire être un atout et je
le considère comme tel pour pouvoir
justement faire les deux à la fois et
rénové et adapté de parti socialiste et
en même temps existé dans le débat
public
le roi vous estimez que vos concurrents
et notamment olivier faure qui fait un
peu figure de favori aujourd'hui ne sont
pas assez charismatique ne pourront pas
porter assez fortement la joie branche
je veux pas faire de commentaires sur
les autres candidats je pense que j'ai
une capacité à porter cette voie et
cette voix du parti socialiste de ce
parti entre jean luc mélenchon et la
république en marche et que c'est un des
enjeux de ce congrès oui mais sinon je
quelle aurait été la justification de ma
candidature c'est pas un problème de
compétence sur le fond c'est pas un
problème
par exemple pour olivier faure qui
aurait été de 2,2 d'avoir été pour
deux roues pas c'est pas le sujet c'est
pas parce que c'est pas la vérité il a
été tout à fait loyal et il était proche
de jean marc ayrault début du
quinquennat et il est resté loyal tout
au long du quinquennat j'ai voté pour
olivier faure pour le groupe
lorsqu'on est arrivé j'avais même
soutenu à la fin du quinquennat
donc je n'ai là-dessus aucun sujet je
considère simplement quelles sont les
questions qui nous sont posées et
comment on y répond je pense que je peux
apporter dans les deux ans qui viennent
parce que pour moi le reste et la suite
c'est pas le sujet prioritaire c'est à
dire 2022 dans les deux ans qui viennent
alors qu'il ya des élections européennes
qui est difficile et qui a des
municipales qu'on doit préparer objectif
municipal il faut qu'on puisse aller
vite et se donner cette force rapidement
et danic rapidement voilà pourquoi je
considère que ma candidature à une
justification
certains en tous les cas et 20 cas et
demande une fusion des candidatures est
coté à ce sujet le sénateur david
assouline
moi je pense qu'il est encore temps de
leur dire à tous et de parcours jouer
les combats anciens une espèce de droite
du parti contre la gauche du parti et
c'est un nom ceux qui croient encore à
ce parti à ce combat et à son histoire
et à son devenir doivent absolument unir
leurs forces
apporter leurs idées et peut trouver la
personne la meilleure si c'est pas un
combat dgo si c'est encore un combat de
personnes ce sera la catastrophe
je justifie c'est de penser qu'on va
refaire alors qu'on est arrivé là où on
en est arrivé avec les divisions vous
avez connu je vais pas rappeler comment
public sénat pouvait avoir ici de gens
qui contestaient à l'intérieur de la
majorité la politique était conduite
parce qu'il y avait des divergences
horizon de fonds si la question consiste
à dire je refais une alliance parce
qu'il faut se rassembler sans essayer à
un moment quand même de redonner de la
clarté
une solidité idéologique et politique un
parti social qu'est ce qui va se passer
mais moi je sais ce qui va se passer
même la belge a reconnu la même chose
que ce qu'on a connu parce que de dire
il ya plus de droite et de gauche du
parti surtout
la part de david assouline qui était
plutôt sur la gauche du parti
et puis de dire comme ça on fait un
grand rassemblement est à peine ce
rassemblement est fait et bien on
recommence
les batailles c'est ce qu'il ne faut
plus c'est bien ça le sujet et d'aborder
la question du congrès en dix ans et les
anciennes méthodes
mais non c'est justement ce que dit
david assouline qui est l'ancienne
méthode cette idée que il suffit de se
rassembler et puis après on verra
oui j'avais le dos à la synthèse
hollandaise h alors là je tourne le ski
et le paradoxe c'est pas moi qui ai pas
mal s'est il fait un para nord c'est que
ce qu'ont contesté la synthèse
hollandaises sont les premiers
maintenant elle revendiqué
j'ai même vu certains dire qu'il fallait
une synthèse nouvelles brutes et ils ont
contesté et la synthèse de hollande je
le rappelle elle s'est faite sur un
sujet qui était majeur d'ailleurs c'est
pas au congrès de dijon n'y a pas eu de
synthèse il avait déjà la question des
retraites vous avez oublié d'en parler
la retraite à 60 ans les durées de
cotisation françois hollande à ce moment
là n'a pas fait de synthèse avec henri
emmanuelli à l'époque du beau monde et
avec arnaud montebourg et vincent
peillon du nouveau parti ceci je
rappelle juste ça dans la synthèse a été
fait sur la question du traité
constitutionnel européen après les
déchirures du oui idée non c'est là
qu'elle a été fait et bien cette
synthèse qui a été fait là après un
débat de congrès d'ailleurs au mans a
été fait et on a bien vu que la question
de laurent est revenu de manière
régulière parce que certains ne pigent
ou pas voulu accepter cette idée que
dans le projet européen ya des
politiques différentes qui peuvent être
conduites
il faut qu'on défende social-démocrate
une politique européenne mais que le
fait a priori de dire c'est l'europe qui
est un problème ça c'est pas la position
qui doit être celle du parti socialiste
jean-françois longy ligne quelle ligne
politique incarné vous qu'est ce qui
vous distingue de vos concurrents dans
la course à la tête du ps quelle ligne
politique
reid seul sur la ligne sur la ligne je
les 10 par rapport à olivet fort qu'est
ce que je pourrais dire d'abord je n'en
sais pas grand chose aujourd'hui mais il
a été avec moi d'ailleurs comme
directeur adjoint au moment où on est et
où j'étais directeur de cabinet de
françois hollande donc je connais
olivier faure
j'attends d'ailleurs ce que va être le
rassemblement qui je le dis comme va de
si j'ai bien compris de martine aubry en
passant peut-être par valérie rabault et
jusqu'à philippe doucet qui était un
proche de manuel valls
je me dis simplement que si on repart
comme ça c'est exactement ce que je vous
dis on risque de se retrouver après le
congrès avec des sujets qui n'auront pas
été traitées et qu'ils se ont traité
qu'après dans l'ain moment où dans des
moments où au contraire on aura besoin
de rassembler profitons de ce congrès
pour essayer de clarifier les choses et
c'est les militants qui doivent choisir
c'est eux c'est leur liberté cette fois
ci on les a trop oublié quand j'étais be
nice
je me suis à chaque fois tenu à aller
voir les militants quand je suis un
démon craignez pas d'être victime d'un
désir des militants de tourner la balle
mais je peux être victime de désir de
tourner la page
vous incarnez quand même beaucoup plus
que olivier faure même si ça peut
paraître injuste à vos yeux le hall en
dise mais voilà compagnonnage de très
longue date avec françois hollande mais
le compagnonnage et la loyauté c'est
quand même là où si je vais quand même
essayer d'expliquer la loyauté que je
vis à vis de françois hollande
la loyauté que j'ai eu en tant que
ministre en vo c'est un acte de
l'agriculture quand je regarde n'importe
quelle collectivité ne demande pas à
ceux qui sont sur la liste d'être loyal
avec le maire ou le président du conseil
départemental mais ça m'est reproché
aujourd'hui au contraire c'est une vraie
valeur la loyauté
il ya suffisamment de trahison pour que
les gens qui sont fidèles et loyaux et
quand même aussi à moi dira alors après
si les militants considèrent qu'il faut
tourner une page mais c'est eux qui
décideront et moi une fois que le
congrès sera finie et bien on se
rassemble et puis le débat il cote il
aura lieu dans le parti socialiste qu'on
choisit les militants point final
moi je ne suis pas là pour continuer le
débat mais je sais une chose c'est que
si on n'a pas un débat un peu clair
cette fois ci est bien les problèmes
c'est pas moi qui les porterait un mois
je ne serai pas un facteur de problème
mais je sais que en regardant tout ça et
en connaissant tout le monde de demain
de manière assez précise
je vois bien les problèmes revenir
derrière voilà donc moi je suis très
transparent très claires j'ai fait ce
que j'ai fait je suis avec
l'agroécologie et les grandes questions
écologiques quelqu'un qui a pris ce
sujet
depuis longtemps sur la question des
inégalités du patrimoine je les avais
une proposition la gelée constater j'ai
constaté ces inégalités il ya déjà plus
d'un an deux ans bientôt et je constate
et je vois avec ce qui est dit partout
que c'est en train de se savent bien
aujourd'hui à l'ordre du jour donc je
vais pas je m'étais pas trompé sur le
sujet écologie à égalité
la question du travail ouais d'accord
parce que c'est très important
patrimoine propositions jb aujourd'hui
que vous regrettez la loi travail les
jeunes je dis que je regrette la le
moment où elle a été faite je les dis je
les dis d'ailleurs ça n'a pas été dit et
moi j'ai pas été le dire en plein
conseil des ministres
je m'en rappellerai et il ya des témoins
qui se rappelle de ce timing et puis
surtout le fait qu' on a commencé une
discussion avec des syndicats avec un
49,3 à peine on avait déposé le texte
donc 1 à bloquer une négociation qui
était nécessaire mais faire ça en 2016
et au printemps 2016 quel moment fallait
faire au début mais il ya eu la loire et
de semaine il y avait des lois qui était
fait avant qu'ils ont été des lois
importantes avec en particulier la
présence des délégués syndicaux dans les
conseils d'administration des
entreprises et des choses de faites on
aurait pu aller et discuter d'autres
sujets mais il fallait faire à la maman
ou c'est pas mal puisque le sujet et
d'arrivée est arrivé en 2016 c'est
devant tout le monde que j'avais dit que
ce n'était pas le bon moment
elle n'a surtout pas d'annoncé les
discussions avec internautes peuvent 3
lorsque vous entendez delphine batho qui
est candidate ou si au poste de premier
secrétaire du ps fustigé un système une
mafia des systèmes de fausses cartes un
contrôle des parrainages fort est ce que
vous vous sentez visé par cette remise
en cause d'un système dont on comprend
qu'au ps il est en vogue depuis
plusieurs plusieurs années des trappeurs
d'abord je trouve que de jeter comme ça
tout seul système mois d'un deuxième
point pendant cinq ans j'ai été au
gouvernement donc le système a
fonctionné sans que je m'en mêle un peu
parce que quand même le parti socialiste
a toujours intéressé et j'ai fais
attention je vous ai dit qu'à chaque
fois que je me déplace et j'allais voir
les militants mais c'est quoi alors le
système qu'est ce que c'est quel est le
reproche qui est fait exactement est
acquis si pour reprocher à tout le monde
et en même temps ne pas proposer des
choses plus plus clair plus plus fort
que moi je ne sais pas ce que veut
dénoncer un coup d'état statutaire
arqués lambert ça fait toujours étriqué
c'est ça ce qu'est le même assisté vote
hongrie de trucs et moi j'avais déjà des
congrès un quand il y avait des débats
dijon il ya eu d'autres congrès qui sont
passés très bien pu y en a eu à qui
s'est mal passé oui ça je m'en souviens
j'en suis là mais c'est au moment où on
partait c'était le congrès de reims
rappellerait et longtemps et je pense
qu'il faut qu'on fasse tout pour éviter
ce genre de problème et donc la
clarification sur les règles la
qualification sur les contrôler la
manière dont on doit aussi valider les
votes et comment il doit s'exercer
ça va faire partie des sujets sur
lesquels il va falloir que les choses
soit transparente et claire
absolument d'accord avec delphine batho
si c'est ça absolument est ce que le ps
est encore en état d'organiser un vote
physique parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
sections où le sujet c'est un vrai sujet
puisqu'il ya eu même pour le vote
statutaire les fédérations qui n'ont pas
organisé
alors il ya certaines à la réunion il y
avait la tempête et puis d'autres parce
que aujourd'hui il ya une difficulté à
faire donc c'est possible
est-ce qu'on peut le faire en si peu de
temps je ne sais pas mais tout doit être
mis sur la table pour faire en sorte que
ce débat se fasse dans la clarté dans la
transparence et que les militants
puissent choisir pour qu'à la fin il y
ait une capacité à se relever tous
ensemble et de manière collective cette
première phase 1 1
il y aura après ce rassemblement autour
du bac 2 c'est absolument nécessaire un
peu à moi il y aura pas de discussion
nous en sommes pas là
merci et nous en sommes pas là nous ne
sommes pas là merci beaucoup stéphane le
foll merci à tous la semaine prochaine
un rendez-vous même heure même émission
est notre invité sera benoît hamon bonne
soirée
[Musique]